[Music]
you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up a cabinet meeting
to find solutions to the cost of living
crisis becomes a row over net zero
we're policy too much coal to slow
climate change a stark warning from a
new report
and climate change or corruption what's
to blame for the devastating floods in
south africa
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world hear from
the people being hit hardest by those
changes and report on the race for
solutions
around has broken out amongst cabinet
ministers over how best to deal with the
uk's cost of living crisis with one
going so far as the call for an overhaul
of net zero targets well let's get more
on this we can speak to sky's deputy
political editor sam code so sam what
are you hearing
britain may have legislated to implement
net zero by 2050. it may have hosted the
cop climate change summit in glasgow but
the basics of that target are still
being fought over in cabinet that
happened earlier today prime minister
boris johnson asked cabinet ministers to
bring ideas to cut people's bills
because the cost of living crisis uh at
this morning's uh cabinet and it quickly
descended into a row over net zero uh
the policing minister kit milhouse
kicked off suggesting that tax cuts were
the answer jacob reese mogg chipped in
that he agreed but he was the one that
once again put those net zero targets on
the agenda at which point quasi quatting
the business secretary whose brief
overseas uh environmental targets uh
came in and defended them he's also gone
public with his defense of net zero
saying on twitter uk
gas generation in april 2022 is around
four times more expensive to run the new
solar or wind farm so mounting a public
defense there another environmental
policy related policy discussed in
cabinet today maybe extending the amount
of time cars can take before having an
mot from one year to two critics suggest
that could mean more dirty cars
potentially more dangerous cars on the
road as a result all of this underscores
how difficult it is uh to tackle the
cost of living crisis and how easy it is
for critics to pick on the net zero
target as a potential area for cost
savings
sam thank you
now too much coal is being burned for
the world to stay within safe
temperature limits that's the conclusion
of a report by the global energy monitor
published today
coal is the biggest single contributor
to global greenhouse emissions so
reducing its use is essential if the
world is to have any hope of limiting
global warming to 1.5 degrees but there
is some good news our science
correspondent thomas more is here to
explain thomas
cole is the dirtiest of all the fossil
fuels the one the world needs to abandon
most rapidly to avoid catastrophic
climate change so how are we doing well
according to a new report by global
energy monitor total coal power capacity
under development fell by 13 last year
down from 525 gigawatts to 457 to reach
a record low but that's where the good
news ends the report shows 34 countries
still had new coal plants in the
pipeline and the operating capacity of
coal plants grew by more than 18
gigawatts as countries delayed plans to
retire power stations because of the
post-covered economic rebound and the
supply crunch in natural gas remember
that was the year of the glasgow climate
pact in which countries agreed to phase
out coal and the urgency was highlighted
by the recent ipcc report by un
scientists to keep the global
temperature rise below the critical 1.5
degrees they said there can be no new
coal plants and coal use needs to fall
by 75 by 2030. we are way off that
target much of the growth in coal was in
china with just over
gigawatts of newly commissioned capacity
as factories opened up again nearly
offsetting all the coal plant
retirements in the rest of the world
and the u.s also slowed its shutdown of
coal plants in 2019 just over 16
gigawatts of coal power was retired in
2021 the estimated switch-off was
between 6.4 and 9. the trend in europe
was more encouraging but the record 12.9
gigawatts of capacity retired in 2021.
now all these figures predate the war in
ukraine that has turbo charged the price
of energy this spring not just oil and
gas but coal too spiked as russia
invaded the eu has said countries could
continue to burn coal as an alternative
to russian gas that's more greenhouse
gas emissions of course and global
energy monitor warns the world needs to
do much more much faster to wean itself
off coal
thomas thanks very much indeed
so let's get some of the day's other
climate news now and environmental
charities have called for the government
to reject plans for the uk's first new
coal mine in over 30 years communities
and local government secretary michael
gove is considering west cumbria
mining's application for a new mine near
whitehaven
14 organizations including greenpeace
have written to mr gove and urged him to
reject the plans saying hundreds of
green jobs in solar power offshore wind
and low carbon heating could be created
instead
the uk government is being urged to
provide at least 900 million pounds to
help stop a famine in east africa oxfam
warns that up to 28 million people are
facing severe hunger in parts of
ethiopia kenya and somalia following a
drought caused by consecutive poor
rainfall seasons the charity says the uk
funding is only a third of what it was
in 2017 with just 288 million pounds
allocated to the countries over the last
year
a brazilian federal court has upheld the
suspension of an environmental license
for what was planned to be the largest
open-pit gold mine in the amazon
rainforest
previously the court ruled that bello
sun mining's consultation with local
indigenous people didn't meet the
criteria required by the national indian
foundation
climate campaigners have warned the mine
would cause significant deforestation
and contaminate nearby rivers which
could threaten local communities
the south african president is sounding
the alarm on the climate crisis more
than 400 people died and more are still
missing after torrential rain led to
flooding and landslides in kwazulu-natal
province the city of durban the
country's largest port and its informal
settlements took the brunt of the
flooding after the heaviest rainfall in
the region in more than 60 years
today in an address to parliament
president ramaphosa warned that the
effects of climate change are now being
felt and the country needs to get
serious about climate adaptation
these storms honorable members
resulting losses of life and the
destruction of key infrastructure
are a reminder that climate change
remains the biggest single threat
to the future of humanity
the south african weather service notes
that extreme weather events
are more prevalent in recent times
across most regions of the country
the effects of climate change are
already being
widely felt
as we rebuild from this disaster
we need to ensure that we are guided
by the principles and approaches
contained
in the adaptation strategy
well joining me now is dr tafadzua
mapaudi professor in climate water and
food systems at the university of
kwazulu-natal
welcome to you first of all do you agree
with the president there that extreme
weather that's being experienced is down
to climate change
uh yes we
we have been experiencing an increasing
frequency
and intensity in weather extremes bought
floods and droughts
in the last couple of years so that's
that's quite accurate
and what about
what this is down to there's been an
extreme loss of life as an extreme
number of buildings damaged as well
is this because those buildings were
inadequately built in the first place do
you think or
simply built in the wrong places
i think the you know the impact of these
floods exposes certain things
mainly the inequality in in south africa
that still persists years after the end
of apartheid
and the fact that a lot of poor people
are still residing
within informal settlements that are
mostly located in you know flood risk
areas and on steep slopes
so naturally those people would be at
risk if there's a flood where they're in
a low lying area landslides if you're on
a steep slope and because they're
settled in formal areas
uh another thing is naturally you know
the the construction of the house is
it's using cheap materials there are
poor people
there's no proper planning there's no
proper retention for slobs
you know the design and management of
slopes so it speaks a lot to the issue
of poverty and inequality that still
persists
which puts people at risk
well yes and cyril ramaphosa is saying
climate change is serious it's here
given that the country is already
suffering from climate change how much
focus is there at the moment on
adaptation
i think
there is a focus on adaptation but it's
clearly been underfunded in recent years
the amount of money that has been you
know channeled specifically towards
climate change adaptation
is is very minimal
and i think it's a dilemma that a lot of
developing countries find themselves in
that are still trying to find economic
development and at the same time we are
having to
now adapt to climate change so that
balance between economic development job
creation alleviating poverty
and then you know climate change
adaptation
uh you know the trade offs in that space
that's one of the challenges that is
there so the serious need to increase
the amount of funding going into climate
change adaptation and also to really
look at the mega projects infrastructure
projects that are being done to ensure
that you know those are planned with
climate change in mind
they are climate resilient and also to
really look a whole lot of other
supporting sectors in the economy that
are sensitive to climate change and that
are vulnerable to it
dr
mapaudi thanks very much indeed
coming up i'll be joined by chief
executive of the climate group helen
clarkson and morgan gillespie from the
food and land use coalition and we're
going to be discussing some long-term
solutions to food insecurity and extreme
weather events brought about by climate
change
[Music]
so
[Music]
i'm david blevins and i'm skye's senior
ireland correspondent
[Music]
i'm based in belfast a city transformed
by peace but still struggling with its
past
politically the two sides are as far
apart as ever and it's over that
question of who has sovereignty in
northern ireland the very issue that's
been the source of tension here for
generations
it takes 60 minutes to cross the irish
sea it took the british monarchy
essentially
i've spent 25 years reporting the
journey from conflict to peace
the political parties of northern
ireland have reached agreement
we help you understand the world with us
today we have reached an agreement with
the conservative party on support for
government in parliament
we already know what the government gets
out of this deal what exactly does the
dup get out of it well 1.5 billion
pounds
welcome to winterfell it's an iconic
location in this globally acclaimed
drama
ophelia was the most powerful hurricane
this far east in the atlantic on record
you can't live in a place like this and
not appreciate the environment
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show on sky news and let's get
straight to some of those climate
stories that we've heard about with
helen clarkson chief executive of the
climate group and morgan gillespie from
the food and land use coalition so
welcome to both of you nice to see you
both
so years of drought and poor harvests
are threatening serious famine across
east africa oxfam has called on the uk
government to help with direct funding
to alleviate the crisis
but in the face of ever worse drought
and with added pressure on food security
from the ukraine war what are the
solutions so morgan to you first of all
east africa then suffering drought so
first of all what impact is climate
change having on food production in
africa
so food prices are surging around the
world they're in record highs in many
countries now this is due not only to
climate change but to conflict such as
the ukraine crisis but also covid
right the consequences caused by the war
in the ukraine are particularly acute
for low-income countries that are
reliant on food and warts such as wheat
or as fertilizer from ukraine and russia
and that includes many countries in
sub-saharan africa many of which have
already seen an increase in malnutrition
rates over recent years so this is
compounding an already quite serious
problem
well yes so helen we've got the problem
of climate change
really causing challenges for
for farmers across places like east
africa but we've also got the war in
ukraine adding complications in there as
well because
of the the problem with the imports of
grains but also fertilizer as well
yeah and i think what we're seeing here
is you know all these uh problems piling
on top of each other and this is what
climate activists have been saying for a
long time in the sense that you've got
all these problems in the world and then
you put climate on top of them or
underneath them and it sort of makes
them even worse and that's why we really
need to think about resilience in the
round and understand that by going after
these things individually you know
that's where missing opportunities to
build a much more resilient future for
everyone okay well let's try and
map out what that resilient future looks
like morgan what would your solutions be
for for local people to try to make sure
that they can boost their productivity
locally
well i mean i think that there's things
that need to happen at multiple levels
right so governments have a role to play
financial institutions have a role to
play trade organization businesses but
there's like five or six things that can
happen pretty urgently that will help
uh mitigate this food crisis so number
one we have to mainta maintain open
flows of trade every nation depends on
this for their food supplies nations
can't start stockpiling food or
resources
number two we need to increase food
production but we need to do this
mindfully and appropriately in different
regions of the world and we need to do
it sustainably and without delay and
that can be in response to the shortages
that we're seeing from the war in
ukraine now what about finance we need
to give the poorest communities around
the world safety nuts that they need to
get through this crisis and that
includes countries in africa and the
middle east and we also need to support
countries again in particular in africa
with the financing that they need for
immediate food supplies right the safety
nets to address the needs of the poor
for small farmers facing higher input
prices
now what else can we do kind of outside
of the global north we think about
things such as relaxing or even
eliminating biofuel mandates at least
temporarily at a time when we're seeing
more people facing hunger the world's
cropland should be used to grow food
not fuel and we really need to avoid
efforts
made to quickly and unsustainably
convert natural land into farmland and
instead concentrate production increases
on already productive lands we don't
want to start destroying nature
destroying the environment to grow new
crops we want to instead really focus on
improving yields on existing
productivity okay
helen what do you make of of those
solutions mapped out and how easy
easy is it to take that that broad of
you when you're in a country that's
suffering right now from famine
i think this is the difficulty and i
think this is where the world's
community needs to kind of come together
and understand and work together on
these long-term solutions and i think
you know kind of broadening out even
from that if we look at what's happening
with the crisis in ukraine you can see
lots of countries and you know we heard
earlier in your report about you know
the uk cabinet meeting today and someone
wanting to jettison these long-term
plans we're not good at long-term
planning we're not good at understanding
complex interconnecting crises and i
think we've got a lot of advice coming
out from our sector and others and what
we need is is governments to sort of
really shift their mindset onto that
long term because the solutions like the
ones that morgan set out are there but
they are complex to implement and
they're going to need real cohesion from
the global community
okay let's move on because the um
massive floods in south africa have left
hundreds of people dead and of course
serious damage we heard a little bit
earlier from president cyril ramaphosa
he's not the only person to attribute
the devastation to climate change but
also poor infrastructure and lack of
investment
shame the blame as well so where does
the balance lie between mitigation
reducing emissions and adaptation to the
effects which are already with us
morgan given that you have got a lot of
people saying that
floods that we're seeing in south africa
are down to climate change given that
climate change is happening now is there
enough focus on adaptation in areas like
that
all right i actually don't think so i
don't think there's enough focus on
adaptation there's certainly not enough
climate finance being pushed towards
adaptation and again it's not that we
don't know the solutions but we're
lacking perhaps the political will the
political might and certainly the
financing to implement those solutions
to help these countries that are already
being
quite clearly impacted in devastating
ways
well yes and helen
clearly preventing climate change is
seen as a huge priority but is the
balance right between the focus on that
and the focus on adapting in areas where
climate change is already affecting
people
yeah i mean i i think we're beyond the
point where we've got a choice between
adaptation
and mitigation or even that they're two
different things now we've got to adapt
to climate change it's here it's
happening we're seeing catastrophes like
the one uh now in south africa if you
look at the figures i've seen un figures
that show that um sort of from 1970 to
2000 the world experienced sort of 90 to
100
medium to large disasters a year in 2015
that number had gone up to 400 and by
2030 we're expecting over 550 that's a
huge difference in what the world needs
to be dealing with so the idea that we
can you know not adapt or understand
that impact isn't there but mitigation
is an important contributor to
adaptation because if we if we want
fewer catastrophes to happen we need to
limit uh the carbon going into the
atmosphere now and try and pull back as
close as we can to that 1.5 degree
target so we need to be doing everything
and i think people
think you know oh we can choose this or
choose that but actually we've really
got to put climate at the heart of all
our decisions now whether those are
infrastructure decisions on you know the
way that you build infrastructure and
the materials you use and how do you
move towards
zero carbon infrastructure the
accelerating the energy transition as
rapidly as possible all of these things
kind of come together to make a more
resilient world where we limit warming
as far as we can and that and then set
ourselves up for surviving that world
that we've created and morgan when you
come to the adaptation part of that it
costs money doesn't it building flood
defenses costs money doesn't it and the
poorer nations would say we contributed
the least to climate change we tend to
be suffering the most and the polluters
ought to pay for it so is that happening
is enough money giving through to the
people that need it
no absolutely not there's not enough
money in the system there's not enough
money being pushed towards these
countries we saw that as an outcome of
cop 26. the big gaps are still around
financing and that's not to say that
other things can't be done you know
there are solutions out there that can
be implemented now one of those things
uh the sort of links to what helen was
talking to is thinking about nature
based solutions particularly within food
and land use systems and they're they're
simple to say but they are hard to
implement but you know we can do things
like just stop deforestation we could
halt deforestation today and that would
make a significant difference in
mitigating emissions and developing
greater sinks to increase our carbon
storage capabilities
linked to that we can also adopt more
productive and regenerative land use
practices right so adapting to climate
change by leveraging new farming
techniques that enable us to produce
more crops on less land and more
regenerative ways that we're protecting
biodiversity protecting fresh water
resources and some of these new
techniques don't cost lots of money
right
you can kind of support farmers in less
expensive ways to start implementing
these now and as helen said we kind of
have to throw all the tools that we have
in the toolkit towards this problem we
really don't have much time to lose okay
and helen we don't have much time
actually left on the program either so
very briefly is the biggest problem
money when it comes to adaptation or a
government's just too short term
i think it's both and i think you know
we've seen the right commitments we're
way forward on where we were paris five
years ago on what governments are
willing to say but now they need the
will to act right away and i think we're
seeing a bit too much we'll look at our
net zero target but we'll just do this
one last bad thing and we we just don't
have time now for one last coal mine or
one last fossil fuel investment we need
to take those targets that governments
have set and make them a reality and
that needs money and it needs will lots
of ideas and solutions uh helen and
morgan very interesting to talk to you
both thanks very much indeed
thank you
so coming up after the roundabout
newspaper comments about angela rayner
trevor phillips and guests will discuss
whether misogyny should be made a hate
crime that's on common ground which is
up next but that's it from me thanks for
watching and i'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you